حرب ظل المتوتره بين اسرائيل وايران تعود
لتشعل المنطقه مجددا بعد الهجوم على منشاه
عسكريه في اصفهان بمسيارات في الاسبوع
الماضي لتواجه طهران اصابع الاتهام
لاسرائيل
صور جديده نشرتها الاقمار الصناعيه
التابعه
مظهره حجم الضرر اللاحق بها والذي تطابق
مع المقاطع التي نشرها اعلام النظام
الايراني وفق ما نشرته وكاله
تطابق في المصدرين يشير الى ان سقف هيكل
المنشاه لربما يكون مبنيا بالدرع القفصي
وهو وسيله لمنع الاستهداف المباشر
بالصواريخ والمسيرات ما يعني ان النظام
الايراني توقع استهدافها قبل الان كما
يثير الشكوك حول الطبيعه المنشاه التي لم
تفصح ايران حتى الان عن نشاطها لترتبط
الخيوط ببعضها ويعود السيناريو تخصيب
اليورانيوم بمستوى تصنيع الاسلحه النوويه
الى الواجهه خاصه بعد فشل محادثات فيينا
للعوده الى الاتفاق النووي الايراني
ورغم ان اسرائيل لم تتبنى الهجوم على
المنشاه الا ان التصعيد الحالي والمخاوف
من النشاط النووي الايراني تزامنا مع عوده
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو الى السلطه
الذي لطالما اعتبر طهران التهديد الامني
الاول في المنطقه والذي ازداد في فتره
حكمه السابقه
بين البلدين وعمر العربيه